[Music]
emma
yeah help me so that i can help you
dad why do i have to talk to you you
don't talk to me it is my job to help
keep you safe maybe you should help
yourself
it's like she's built this fortress
around herself so that nothing can hurt
her
em
em you're uh okay
are you okay she got some panic attacks
look at me look at me i know where
you're at
what did you say to her
[Music]
oh god
hi i wanted to say sorry for wrecking
your universe
you coming in to check on emma was a
very thoughtful gesture i did hit you
both with my car you did and i am
planning on suing
i find it very easy to be in your
company you know that yeah it's been a
while for me too
why did you run away from me i'm a
complicated person i've got baggage
after the accident when i was scared you
said that you'd be there too i have a
bunch of times
my life is a mess messy is good
[Music]
i've never shared this with anyone
before
i'm not perfect either felt like the
universe was bringing us together what
did this happen for a reason
how did your husband
die
we've all got wolves in us
you just have to make sure you feed the
right one
[Music]
this is me this is who i am
you